[Musique]
bonsoir je vais commencer par une
citation une citation que j'aime
beaucoup
de sacha guitry qui nous dit ne pas
aller au théâtre c'est comme faire sa
toilette sans miroir et je vais vous
poser une petite question aussi combien
d'entre vous si vous pouvez lever la
main ne sont pas allés au théâtre les
six derniers mois à l'opéra qui n'est
pas aller à l'opéra ok je suis un peu
rassuré rassurer dans le sens où ça
ressemble quand même à la à la
statistique que j'ai lu ce matin
plus ou moins qui nous dit que oui pour
% des citoyens sont allés en belgique à
au théâtre ces six derniers mois
heureusement qu'on fait un an sa double
un peu sa vie à 19% mais c'est la moitié
à l'opéra une personne sur vingt est
allé à l'opéra ces six derniers mois
vous avez compris je vais vous parler de
la façon dont dont les gradins et les 4
200 sont un moment des miroirs de ce
qu'on raconte sur le plateau et je vais
aussi vous parler d un peu de ma famille
ma famille c'est quelque chose dont
c'est une famille de je suis de deuxième
génération d'immigrés italiens du côté
de mon père espagnol
du côté de ma mère alors ma mère est
arrivée très petit mais ses frères
étaient plus âgés et c'est une famille
dans laquelle il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
culture une culture enfin je euros pour
la définition d'une escaut qui nous dit
qu'est ce que c'est la culture pour en
prendre une
la culture dans son sens le plus large
est considéré comme l'ensemble des
traits distinctifs spirituels et
matériels intellectuels et affectifs qui
caractérise une société ou un groupe
social allant globe
outre les arts et les lettres les modes
de vie les droits fondamentaux de l'être
humain
les systèmes de valeurs les traditions
et les croyances suis chez moi il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de cultures
alors mes maisons quand ils sont arrivés
d'espagne ils ont mis de la culture dans
leur valise parce que l'espagne était
très loin il ya 60 ans était un pays
très éloignés
ils ont pris leurs taureaux leur tête de
taureau en paille et leur infliger deux
corridas pour les mettre au mur dans
leur appartement ou leur maison ici
d'ailleurs quand mes cousins aujourd'hui
qui sont nés en espagne viennent
dévoiler les affiches de corridas bon ça
c'est une autre histoire
en tout cas nous on fait aussi des
grandes fêtes des grandes fêtes
alors pour ça on loue des espaces des
buvettes de terrain de football où des
choses parce qu'évidemment toutes nos
maisons les maisons des uns et des
autres sont beaucoup trop petite pour
accueillir toute la famille forcément
et c'est des grandes fêtes ou baiia le
ti alphone socket à l'entrée qui coupent
du jambon il
il a un bras beaucoup plus musclé claude
d'ailleurs parce que on est beaucoup et
la règle du jeu c'est que c'est qu'on
parle tous tous ensemble plus forts les
uns que les autres et la salle résonne
assez fort et sain des grands mystères
de la culture méditerranéenne
on arrive à se comprendre à aimer ça
voilà et mettant tout de suite la même
idée c'est faire de la tortilla voilà
site entre la tortilla et et mon jeu
avec les cousins et des cousines
évidemment c'est de faire le blind test
ortiz qui consiste à reconnaître qui a
fait quoi et à donner un prix à la fin
mais ça je vais m'en gardé d'en parler
parce que faris de représailles
familiale bon malgré tout malgré cet
excédent de culture dans lequel on a
vécu avec les cousines qui danse danses
traditionnelles tout ça je me rends
compte que j'ai peu de souvenirs de nous
assis au milieu d'une rangée d'une salle
comme celle ci on était plutôt des
spectateurs debout pas des spectateurs
assis on allait souvent voir des
concerts des choses ou alors des
événements organisés par la ville où il
y avait une salle de concert on était là
on était debout regarder le spectacle
mais rarement à 6 alors pourquoi
pourquoi les classes ouvrières sont l
absence des théâtres je pourrais pas
vous l'expliquer ici en si peu de temps
et certainement que l'on serait même pas
capable c'est un travail de longue
haleine qu'il faut faire un travail de
fond
par contre je vais vous parler d'une
expérience récente il ya quelques
semaines j'étais à new york parce que
j'étais invité à programmer des
spectacles dans un festival pour les
ramener peut-être ici en europe dans le
théâtre dont je m'occupe et comme
j'étais à new york par le festival
c'était le soir l'inspecteur je me dis
bon la journée je vais quand même
allez voir c'est quoi le metropolitan
museum quand même c'est la première fois
de ma vie que j'y suis et je peux vous
dire c'est quelque chose je suis pas
très habitué des musées d'art
contemporain mais à chaque fois que je
fais une vie que j'aime bien en voir un
parce qu'ils sont toujours des marqueurs
identitaires de la ville et surtout la
moitié des gens qui sont là bas sont là
juste pour monter sur le toit parce que
c'est toujours les plus beaux paysages
de la ville qu'on a mais donc moi je
suis rentré dans ce grand hall très
impressionnant et je cherchais d'abord
partout où acheter mon ticket et puis
pourquoi acheter mon ticket parce que
c'était enfin en gros j'ai pris un
ticket pour une expo qui n'était pas une
expo qui était juste une oeuvre et qui
était pas du tout ce que je croyais mais
peu importe j'avais fait le metropolitan
museum et l'après midi et après ça je
suis allez à broadway parce qu'il faut
voir broadway et times square les écrans
c'est quand même quelque chose par
contre acheter un ticket c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que tout est plein
depuis plusieurs mois et donc il faut
aller sur des sites avec deux revendeurs
il faut pas se faire arnaquer peu
importe le soir j'étais dans ce festival
dans lequel justin vite et j'ai vu un
spectacle un spectacle tels que ce que
je présente ici à bruxelles et je me
suis dit bon ouais c'est chouette on va
l'accueillir en europe
et quelque part j'étais chez moi et le
lendemain j'ai hésité à aller voir
harlem une messe de gospel parce que
tout le monde y met farley voir une
messe gospel est incroyable c'est
incroyable d'autant plus que j'aime bien
les cultures hip hop qui en sont dérivés
et et j'ai pas osé parce que je ne
pratique aucune religion et je me suis
dit je n'ai pas les codes et on peut
toujours parler du fait qu'il est clair
qu'il faut élargir les publics
on peut critiquer les opérateurs est ce
que les salles savent suffisamment les
opérateurs savent suffisamment qui est
dans la salle mais aussi qui n'est pas
dans la salle esquire on a des
statistiques qui permettent d'établir
qui ne vient pas au théâtre
est ce qu'on met des moyens financiers
directement alloués pour l'élargissement
des publics pour asseoir dans nos salles
des personnes qui ne s'y à sait jamais
qui sont des spectateurs et les
spectatrices debout mais je suis pas là
pour vous parler ça je suis là pour vous
parler de la peur la peur réelle
le danger le risques incommensurables
que représente
fait de pousser une porte de théâtre
pour la première fois déjà rien que
passer devant ce que vous avez vu nos
théâtres nos salles de spectacles sont
des bâtiments qu'ils soient classiques
ou modernes toujours très très
impressionnant
alors vous allez me dire un stade de
foot c'est impressionnant aussi mais un
théâtre ça ressemble plus à rien de tel
dans lequel on a pas moyen de rentrer on
dirait bon je vais pas prendre un café
là dedans quand même pas à moi et puis
surtout quand on y est belle
architecture les places les plus chères
sont pas forcément celles où on voit le
mieux le spectacle
elles sont souvent celles où vous voit
le mieux et surtout après le spectacle
quand n en était qu un groupe d'amis qui
a l'habitude d'aller au spectacle pas
osé dire ce qu'on en pense sur la
peinture n'est pas les codes de l'opéra
n'en parlons pas et aussi voir le
spectacle
être assis croatie au milieu de ces
dangers on peut refermer un livre c'est
facile un concert on peut très bien se
dire bon je vais je vais changer de
scène je suis dans un festival ou alors
je vais chercher un bar ou alors je vais
parler fort à mon ami parce que j'ai le
moins à ce morceau ou sortir
par contre quand on est au milieu d'une
rangée se lever ou mieux d'un silence
dans deux notes de mozart ou mieux d'un
monologue mais ça devient un peu plus
compliqué parce que l'équipe est le
théâtre c'est une autre expérience du
temps et notre monde notre société nos
modes de consommation culturelle ne
correspondent pas du tout à nos modes de
consommation tout court notre monde
n'aime pas les autres expériences du
temps quelque part il ya aussi le prix
le prix combien coûte un siège de
théâtre imaginez-vous tout le monde
s'est dit ici au fond peut-être que
j'aime pas le théâtre y en a qui se sont
pas dit j'aime pas le terrain dans leur
vie monsieur vous avez un abonnement
international non blague à part on s'est
tous dit tous peut-être que ça m'ennuie
peut-être que je n'aime pas le théâtre
est ce que vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
s'est dit en fait je crois que j'aime
pas la musique
on peut ne pas aimer la peinture de pmu
le théâtre ne pas aimer la musique c'est
quelque chose de plus difficile mais si
imaginez vous deviez payer à chaque fois
15 euros pour écouter un morceau de bob
marley rien pour savoir si vous aimez le
reggae ou un morceau de monteverdi juste
pour savoir si vous aimez le baroque à
chaque fois ces 15 euros
ces 15 euros et 15 euros bon quelque
part le théâtre coûte cher à voir des
gens ici et maintenant devant nous qui
travaillent on a la chance de vivre dans
un système où l'auteur times n'est pas
complètement séparée du secteur public
est quelque part tous les gens qui
payent pour le théâtre c'est à dire à
peu près tout le monde devrait se sentir
légitime d'y être et je voudrais aussi
vous parler du fait qu'il est peut-être
impossible au fond de ne pas aimer le
spectacle qu'est ce qu'un spectacle le
théâtre c'est pas une activité vierge
vous avez des professeurs qui vous ont
donné envie et qu'ils vont communiquer
peut-être le virus du théâtre des profs
de philo de littérature comme ça a été
mon cas mais vous avez peut-être des
professeurs qui ont fait tout à fait
inverse qui ont fait en sorte que vous
ne retenez plus jamais là bas puis
jamais la télévision regarder l'image du
théâtre qu'on nous donne à la télévision
le théâtre de la télé ressens pas du
tout aux terres du théâtre le théâtre de
la télé ressemble à une toute petite
portion du théâtre du théâtre
et pourtant il n'est pas possible de ne
pas aimer un spectacle qu'est ce qu'un
spectacle par exemple
asseyez vous faites l'exercice vous
asseyez sur un banc dans la rue et vous
regardez vous imaginez quelqu'un a mis
tout ça en scène les passants trop
pressé le l'oiseau qui passe ces
passants qui ne voit pas du tout ce sans
abri qui est là et que vous voyez pas ce
que c'est ça aussi le théâtre ça vous
permet de voir aussi les invisibles et
vous vous dites waouh quel mise en scène
quel spectacle je suis ému parce que
c'est vrai et pas besoin d'acteurs un
regard d un coucher de soleil super
coucher de soleil vous êtes tout seul
avec le soleil et vous dites waouh c'est
beau quel spectacle
je suis ému parce que c'est beau votre
chaton du deuxième étage fait un triple
salto tombe sur ses pattes
vous vous dites waouh quel spectacle je
suis ému par la prouesse technique mais
le plus beau c'est quand même quand vous
vous dites quel spectacle et que vous et
ému sans comprendre pourquoi vous êtes
ému et
si vous venez un jour dans ma famille
vous êtes tous invités
si vous venez dans ma famille vous vous
allez certainement m'appelait le week
end avant pour me dire mais comment doit
s'habiller
vous allez arriver peut-être que j'aurai
invités certainement certains d'entre
vous mais peut-être un mètre de qaraqosh
ce sont des marionnettes traditionnelles
turques un mètre de butô c'est une forme
de danse japonaise
le premier violon du chef d'orchestre de
leur caisse philharmonique national mais
vous allez tous vous ruer sur le jambon
de thio iphone sort vraiment savoir quel
parti manger en fait et vous allez
perdre au blind test de la tortilla
c'est sur mes parents il est vrai quand
je me suis inscrit au conservatoire
n'étant pas des spectateurs assis ont eu
peur mais comme je dois les remercier
d'une chose ils m'ont fait promettre de
me diriger vers une chose dont je
pensais qu'elle me rendrait heureux et
bien ils l'ont accepté alors j'ai fait
mes études
ils ont plus ou moins cru mais le jour
où ils m'ont vu à la télé à côté de
salvatore adamo là ils sont d'ivoire
c'est bon c'est bon
ouf moi je me suis dit bon on sait
peut-être pas pour ça réellement que ils
comprennent peut-être pas pour l'airé
les raisons profondes pour lesquelles je
le fais mais c'est pas grave
voilà ça me rassure qu'ils soient
rassurés et puis un jour j'ai fait ma
première mise en scène dans laquelle je
jouais pas j'étais pas sur le plateau et
là ils se sont dits tous ces gens sont
assis pour écouter ce que mon fils a à
dire est ce que j'avais à dire c'était
aussi ce qu'il m'avait appris dans cette
culture familiale mon frère des années
plus tard à fait mon unique frère on est
deux dans la famille un fait les mêmes
études que moi et tout à coup ils ont
commencé à aller voir ce que lui faisait
forcément ils s'étaient plus obligés
d'aller voir que mes exercices du
conservateur et les eaux sont mis à
comparer une société mieux ça s'est
moins bien et avec bienveillance bien
sûr et puis plus le temps avance et ils
ont commencé à préférer que le travail
avec tel compositeur musical plutôt
qu'avec un autre
et voilà et puis c'était pas facile
parce que quand j'étais acteur qu'une
autre personne jouer ma mère ma mère
était très jalouse
très énervé
mais ouais non mais l'un dans l'autre
au final on en arriver à un point où il
allait voir des spectacles où ils vont
aujourd'hui voir des spectacles dans
lequel ni mon frère ni moi nos jours et
c'est très énervant aussi parce qu'ils
disent non ça c'est bien moi je suis pas
daccord fabre soit ils ont appris à être
de vrais spectateurs parce qu'ils aident
spectateurs ça s'apprend à n'importe
quel âge de la vie et ils n'ont pas fait
seul parce que il y a deux autres
endroits essentiels fondamentaux dans
l'évolution d'un d'une éducation et d'un
individu c'est également la rue la
culture dans les clubs de sport les
fines partager avec les amis de la rue
est aussi l'école je vais vous raconter
une petite anecdote des amis jouer sur
scène devant un parterre de jeunes
publics 8 14 ans et comme c'est souvent
le cas dans le théâtre jeune public va y
avait un groupe et un individu en
particulier qui maquille qui perturbait
un petit peu la présentation dans ce cas
là qu'est ce qu'on fait on envoie des
axes regard on le tient et l'acteur
reprend la main sur le gradin
chevauchent à peu son audience mais il
ya un professeur derrière qui
connaissait son d'éléments perturbateurs
qui n'a pas laissé l'acteur faire son
travail et il a tapé sur la mode des
pôles des gamins sur l'épaule du gamin
et lui a dit si tu continues tu vas
aller faire le clown sur scène avec les
autres alors ce gamin là elle aura pas
appris à être spectateur comme les
autres non plus pensent peut-être que ce
gamin là et il aurait fallu lui dire bah
t'es pas d'accord avec ce qu'ils font
tutu aussi toit des éléments culturels à
mener sur le plateau vas-y emmène les
n'ai pas peur peut-être que il aurait
fallu en faire un constructeur
d'histoire on nous parle de diversité
aujourd'hui on a besoin de différents
sur les plateaux si on parle de
diversité c'est parce qu'il ya
discrimination c'est parce que le cadre
de scène d'un théâtre est le miroir de
son public mais plus tellement le miroir
de la réalité c'est à dire que le
théâtre a beau être beau il a beau être
vrai
il a beau avoir de la prouesse technique
il n'est plus du tout le miroir d'une
réalité et on peut plus faire sa
toilette au théâtre alors pour ça je
pense qu'il faut vraiment casser l'image
des artistes auprès des jeunes artistes
bohèmes ouvrir les écoles d'art les
écoles d'art quand on s'inscrit dans une
école d'art
ce ne doit pas être juste parce que mes
parents m'ont emmené au théâtre parce
que je suis né dans une famille de
spectateurs assis il faut dire à cet
enfant si tu n'es pas là si tu n'es pas
sur scène il ya des histoires qu on ne
racontera pas tuer important pour fonder
des mythes contemporains et moi j'espère
qu'au tour de ce théâtre dans les
quartiers qui jouxte le théâtre il ya
des god hard et mozart des de vinci et
des van gogh dans les greniers et dans
les chambres d'ados et aujourd'hui comme
je voulais dit je programme dans un lieu
culturel et donc je conseille mes
parents sur ce qu'ils peuvent voir mais
je ne suis pas leur programmateur je
suis leur conseiller ils sont devenus
les programmateurs de leur propre saison
culturelle et donc si vous avez le
billet le bras si vous n'êtes pas allés
au théâtre les six derniers mois
j'espère vous avoir donné peut-être
envie dit d'y aller les six prochains
mois
et sinon bah allez prendre un café que
votre maman et dit merci
voilà merci
[Musique]